let's talk about we'll talk about
acquisitions but let's talk about
Alibaba first because the stock jumped
when she confirmed that the spin-off was
going according to plan despite these
proposed changes coming from the IRS how
significant is that well usually Sigma
is significant I mean a big part of that
35 38 billion dollar market cap for
yahoo is investors expectations around
the Alibaba spin-off and when the IRS
earlier this year that they were
changing the pack Charles around it the
stock price fell now Marissa said today
that maybe maybe maybe they were kind of
grandfathered in we'll see what the IRS
says but for now it's good news for
Cheryl know it's interesting this
question we've continued to ask this
question over the years a yahoo a media
company or a technology company I
believe Steve Jobs is the one who
originally said look yahoo you have to
choose kevin how satisfied were you with
her answer that we can be both and in
fact being both is a strength i think it
can be a strength it's a wanted one of
the things that's really are in the
valley is like an engine typical
engineering mindset like doesn't really
understand i think a typical media
mindset and that's one of yahoo
strengths like they've got a lot of
history a lot of history there and like
the fact that that's the direction the
marissa is pushing pushing the company
and i think is actually good now it
sounds to me when it comes to
acquisition like yahoo is still on the
hunt would you agree probably not for
anything big i don't think that she has
the runway that she had when she joined
the
me two years ago to make big
acquisitions fairly small ones she's
certainly spending on content though I
see that as kind of her her big target
right now that NFL deal is Stephanie met
have pointed out in that interview was
not awarded to yahoo by the NFL right
they paid for it and and Marissa said
look we really wanted in Kevin you
helped integrate AdMob when Google
bought it back in the day Marissa said
something about Yahoo being a scary
place when talking about acquisition she
was she was speaking to entrepreneur
there a lot of people said I don't want
to come work at Yahoo though she feels
things have changed since then you know
you know what do you think the
perception is of selling to yahoo at
this stage all right think certainly
Marissa has improved things and you know
like she understands like the three
things you have to get right for for
acquisitions to succeed like you have to
have like products energy you know so
the thing that you're buying has to
augment the things that you're trying to
accomplish in your company you have to
make sure that the vision and the
passion of the entrepreneur that you're
bringing into the company aligns with
what you want them to do inside of your
big enterprise and then you have to give
them enough space to operate like you
can't sort of crush them with
bureaucracy and you have to buy them a
little bit of freedom and like
Marissa I think through her experience
at Google knows all of this stuff but
that said like they bought a lot of
companies and like it's hard work so I
think it makes a lot of sense for them
to digest what they've what they've
swallowed rather than trying to like
pile on more big big acquisition we'll
have to see if these acquisitions that
she's made thus far stand the test of
time okay